[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not mad I'm just disappointed
go easy look how sad they are give him
up now I have something from your dad
before he died he told me I'd know when
to give it to you and he was right
so dangers what a book for you trying to
read it where's that China my dad left
this book for me my brothers they
shouldn't weird stuff happening to me
dad is that you me you're a go go where
what no I can't you can do it I know you
can
why it's been in the clouds a little
recently and I guess we all have well
well well if it isn't wider mom okay
everything it's going to be great I just
wanted to help Mom out the key is to
figure out how nature put away from my
face did you face away from my but
nothing works if we don't stick together
my mother dad never let them click put
together everything you've learned dad
always said can't succeed unless you
willing to fail it was word you might
have been gone forever I am here for you
always
[Music]
the very best player who ever sat down
at a poker table hey it's his fantasy
[Applause]
you